es el primer positivo en la villa
olímpica y se conoce a seis días de la
inauguración del evento se trata de un
integrante de una de las delegaciones
extranjeras que dio positivo el viernes
hemos tomado medidas para asegurar la
seguridad en la villa olímpica con la
situación actual que surjan casos
positivos es en sí mismo algo que
debemos asumir como tal tomaremos las
medidas adecuadas para que los atletas
que residen allí puedan sentirse seguros
por seguridad no se informó su nombre ni
su nacionalidad los organizadores sólo
señalaron que no es un atleta y
agregaron que están recopilando
información sobre los contactos cercanos
que pudo tener la noticia encendido las
alarmas pues la villa olímpica ubicada
en una de las islas artificiales de la
bahía de tokio albergará a unos 11 mil
deportistas e integrantes de
delegaciones de igual forma fueron
reportados 14 nuevos casos de personas
vinculadas a los olímpicos dos de
integrantes de medios de comunicación
siete de contratistas y cinco de
personal de logística lo que eleva más
de 40 el total de positivos registrados
durante el mes de julio de personas
relacionadas con el evento
el presidente del comité olímpico
internacional thomas bach aseguró que el
caso dentro de la villa olímpica no
supone un riesgo para los deportistas
sin embargo las protestas para que los
olímpicos no se lleven a cabo no cesan
esta semana fue presentada una petición
con más de 450 mil firmas para que se
cancelen quiero que cancelen los
olímpicos inmediatamente el evento
perjudica el país anfitrión de lo que se
encuentra bajo su cuarto estado de
emergencia desde el inicio de la
pandemia